[Music]
this is leviathan Studio where we do a
PO Retreat every uh every year as you
come
sometime I want to talk about the secret
to how to do these different wall plane
bua flower combinations so understanding
the patterns are is one thing but doing
it smoothly is another and the way I
like to do it is being able to keep my
hands very close so it all looks like a
buzz
saw and it's a bit of a secret to how to
do that with the
planes most people when they start
spinning poi if they try to keep a wall
plane they're po tend to do this I'm
going to call that convex so it's a a
little bit towards uh wheel planes but
just a little bit almost wall plane but
a little bit
convex the trouble with that is look at
the angle I've got here look at my right
POI the orange one that angle makes it
want to hit the left po or the left arm
boom I can't get my right hand anywhere
close to my left hand because it's going
to hit something same thing with the
left po the left PO is coming down angle
towards my right arm if I can keep a
really straight wall plane it's better
see with a straight wall plane at least
I'm not going to hit the other poy so I
can start
having everything
closer but if I put my planes angled a
little bit towards my chest uh concave
planes then check this out if I go into
a half Buzz saw and a half bu saw is
where my right PO is INS in between my
arms
but my left PO is outside my arms so I
call that a half Buzz saw as opposed to
a full buz
saw my right PO is now angled up inside
my arm it's angled towards my elbow or
my
armpit and I can switch and my left PO
is also angled towards uh the right
elbow or armpit so with these planes
either PO is going to fit inside the
opposite arm so I could do say switchy
switch where I'm switching Wich Poise
inside and look how close my hands are I
can get them touching in between the
switch Boop touch touch
touch those planes are what allow me to
do all the buz wall plane flowers
smoothly so watch as I do this say this
is anti- spinning
both see the left POI comes down inside
the right arm and the right po comes
comes up inside the left arm so as I go
through this pattern I can even work on
trying to keep my hands brushing each
other through the entire
pattern and I can go through my
different switches where now my right is
anti spin my left is in spin or they can
both be in
spin or my left uh let's see what the
other way or my left is anti Spin and my
right is in spin now it's possible to do
all of that with straight or con uh
convex planes but your hands will never
get nearly as close so if my planes are
straight I could do it a little closer
if they're convex I have to keep my
hands really far apart um but it's by
making them
concave that I can actually get my hands
[Music]
touching so there's a lot of uh there's
a lot of tips um some of the stuff I
will of course post publicly in Facebook
and YouTube uh and there's some other
things that I'm only going to put in my
online courses or on the patreon page um
but of course it's those people that are
supporting me through patreon and the
online courses that I can spend so much
time making these videos so it also
means more videos for you whether you
decide to support me that way or not of
course it takes time to
practice to actually learn to
invert both your planes and the secret
there is really just doing one po at a
time so say you get both your PO going
clockwise just the right learn to bring
it inside your arms it'll be going
forward the left fo if it's going
clockwise if you invert the plane it's
going to be going backwards right will
go forwards left will go backwards when
you do them both I can almost guarantee
that the first thing you'll want to do
is come into a buzz
saw but it won't be if you do it right
it's going to be right forward left
backward so you can actually start that
way with the right forward and the left
backward and try to go back to wall
plane or start on wall plane come back
to your opposites um try it each way if
it doesn't work do the right bends
forward left bends into backwards right
bends in between the arms to go forward
left bends in between the arm to go
backward start them both go to a wall
plane start in a wall plane get back to
your inverted uh your split time
opposites buzza eventually you will get
it or you can bend the planes in Bend
the planes out and then all you need is
a little bit uh concave just a little
bit and that's going to let you do
this we both are fitting inside the
opposite arm and once you can do that
smoothly this stuff will get way
easier so I really hope that helps cuz I
I think that whole all the split time
buds saw stuff is just so much fun and
uh looks so nice so great to play with
um and I hope we having a great
day I'm going to go play in the floor